[Music]
when you're a kid the world
all of it seems magical doesn't it not
all of it well yeah yeah i mean you
don't remember when everything was
magical yeah when you're a baby
everything probably seems magical yeah
exactly i don't remember being a baby
though one of my first childhood
memories was seeing darth vader on the
big screen i remember watching movies
that's magic yeah yeah i was thinking
that was magical but i just saw baby at
jersey mike's and the baby was like
looking at the sandwich fix at the same
toppings at jersey mike's are pretty
magical they're mad they're fun but like
i could it looked like the kid was like
in wonder it was like experiencing
wonder by looking at these and um and i
remember our nephew a couple weeks ago
we got him a magic eight ball you know
you'd ask it a question and he would ask
a question and like is it is it cold
outside and then
all signs point to yes or like are we
eating dinner soon and it's like outlook
not so good it's like i guess dinner's
still an hour away yeah so you'd have to
like finesse the truth a little bit it's
fun to trick kids is that what it is i
think so
because i was thinking like it also
feels like fun to have that kind of it
was a power that like they're amazed by
something like they're amazed by magic
it's fun maybe it's just fun to trick it
maybe well let's talk about it
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life for short i am
your host the amazing justin
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is the what would
your uh magician name be
the
mediocre
christian
the quite unimpressive justin
um yeah it wouldn't be amazing the
amazing kresgen who else was amazing i
mean it's hard to really be amazing to
be amazed by something it takes a
certain kind of person to name
themselves the amazing something yeah
that's a whole lot i will never be that
kind of person even if i was amazing at
something i don't think i'd ever be the
kind of person to describe i know who
would reference that
reference your talent
right exactly that way because kresgen
what did he do he guessed people's he he
he was telling i don't know i don't know
for the record i don't believe that
magic 8 balls are magic i know but i
think most people knew that but we had a
struggle with our nephews i was there
that day and our father was trying to
convince him that it
wasn't magic
which there's something i understood why
you don't want to deceive a kid and you
want them to be able to think rationally
you want to like demystify exactly but
but we were trying to trick him yeah i
guess so but weirdly
our father is uh catholic is very um uh
has a lot of faith in the catholicism
and so there are elements of that faith
that are quite magical i think
well it depends how you use the word
magical i think
right i don't know if it's like magic
8-ball magical no or like our guest
today
type of magic yes well i guess yeah so
that's why we're talking about the magic
k-pop and and magic in general um
because our guest today
uh makes everyone believe in magic not
just little kids who are easy to trick
with a
toy filled with water what is that blue
substance is that just the uh is it it's
clear water but is it just like a blue
it just looks like windex yeah it might
just be windex
yeah maybe i don't think it's i don't
think the liquid is actually blue is it
i think it is i think the the little
thing itself
is white because when it pops up close
enough to the surface yeah you're right
it you can see that it's white you're
right you're white
um that was really stupid i i i hope we
can cut that out i mean we can cut it
out but it also might be fine
i hope we keep that in yeah my stupidity
justin long warts it all
that's an embarrassing war have you ever
had a wart i have yeah but you had one
on your foot right underneath my big toe
i remember there was a kid in
kindergarten who i really falls into the
category of who cares by the way yeah
maybe
uh there are a couple people there made
some like real shorties who might care
there's maybe some foot fetishes yeah
and actually foot fetishes wouldn't want
it oh right that's right that'd be a
doubt that would that's true i don't
think there are people who have
fetishized words maybe
but there was a kid i don't want to say
his name um
i'll call him uh
bjorn
uh because he was also of scandinavian
but it wasn't bjorn uh in kindergarten
it was a friend of mine and we there was
a part of the school day where we'd have
to hold hands i forget what it was i
think it was like the teacher was
introducing something um and we'd all
hold the hands it was nice
and
i would always this
means i would always try to avoid being
next to bjorn because he had warts all
over his hand not because he was
scandinavian no no if anything that
would draw me to him
uh no but i and the few times and
sometimes i could work on his hand yeah
his palm
ball in the back of his hand back from
all over you're sure there are warts
sports wow yes well anyway uh why have
we strayed so far off the magic path why
are we talking about uh magic and magic
8 balls well i know why
can i say yeah yeah i'm very excited to
say yeah but you don't often get to say
it
you can say it no no no i feel bad this
is the thing you do she didn't feel bad
i just thought because i don't want to
break the formula i know you like
formula it's a very exciting guest go
ahead david copperfield yes the david
copperfield he's the
the biggest i mean he's the a magician
of a lifetime he's one of the few
world famous magicians he's the only
living illusionist who has a star on the
hollywood walk of fame i mean say no
more right uh well we we should say a
little bit more because it's uh much
longer no no more that's it for the show
he's an icon he's a legend he's a living
legend he is he really is it was um
somebody i've been aware of since i was
a little kid he used to have those big
specials on t i mean i grew up we grew
up watching him and um
it was what a what a thrill he's like
our uh houdini right he is what an
accomplishment for somebody and for us
for our little show to have the modern
day houdini well don't belittle our show
well i'm just saying it's an
accomplishment david copperfield is a
big guest for our show he's bigger than
the show he is definitely bigger than a
chef
he might be bigger than every podcast
he's huge yes and so
uh we were so appreciative uh that he
came on of his time and so we're excited
for you to hear it he also has a brand
new book out called david copperfield's
history of magic oh it is and who better
to write that book with that big of a
title broad of a title than david
copperfield anyway we talk about the
book but mostly we talk about what it's
like to be david copperfield he's one of
those people i've always just been
curious like what is it like to be you
i'm so excited world let's hear it okay
here we go with the the amazing safe to
say
uh you can't say that very often amazing
sounds almost like an understatement he
amazes people for a living yes he is the
amazing david copperfield and he's our
guest right now on life is short life
could be a dream
this episode of life is short is brought
to you in part by audible gather the
family for story time magic with audible
listen to imaginative heartwarming and
festive stories original podcasts and
more brought to life by incredible
performers enjoy brand new audible
originals like the cinnamon bear
and exclusives like the christmas pig by
jk rowling fire up modern classics like
harry potter and the sorcerer's stone
and so many more all-time favorites
now's the time to listen together go to
audible.com
listen together
that's audible.com
listen together listen now only from
audible
hello hello
[Music]
i just want to describe for people
listening if anyone's listening how
eclectic your background is david it's
amazing but physically the background
here or yes
oh is that an actual background or is it
one of those zoom no no no it's it's
real who knows with you
people must constantly be questioning
the reality when you're around
but where are you exactly
i'm in
the opening section of my museum oh wow
it's uh uh in fact it's where the book
begins this is the magic shop i
recreated this magic shop
um uh are we on by the way i think so
yeah believe it or not this is this is a
show oh okay
what is a show
you referenced the book it's it's uh
david copperfield's history of magic
it's you talk about 28 really
influential magicians throughout time
and uh well how did this start how did
your museum start i want to know
everything well this is the beginning of
my career actually this is a
magic shop that i recreated from my
childhood that is so cool yeah and the
brick and mortar magic shop is getting
less and less you know yeah less of that
happening which is in one case kind of
sad the internet is amazing it's got
good points and bad points right
but uh this is where kind of it began
for me magic shops were all over the
world and you know when i came into this
place it was called tannins in new york
you'd go from an elevator 13 floors
floor it wasn't labeled 13 because i
thought it was bad luck in those days
it would be like the 14th floor
isn't that people might not know that i
just recently learned this that in new
york the buildings is it i don't know if
it in every building but it's it goes
yeah 12 to 14 the floors
how strange yeah and they really uh
that's what it was but the uh the
building was an amazing place you'd go
up in the woo it was the wurlitzer
building in new york where they had
pianos in the front and you go up the
the elevator and you walk out and you
were here and you felt like you were in
heaven
and it wasn't just magic stuff you'd see
johnny carson working on this side and
you'd see orson welles practicing magic
and you see
god uh
even j.j abrams has a ted talk
about
about uh going to tannins and his whole
ted talk is really about how his
storytelling and his was informed by his
um
interest in magic as a youth
and uh so we recreated that shop in fact
jj came here
and you know everybody gets very
emotional when they've
experienced this kind of thing to come
here and see this again it's really a
kind of a amazing thing but that started
me off really so what what are your
earliest memories of going there david
would you would you see those greats
that you mentioned would you see like
orson welles and um and would you have
interactions with those people yeah
literally yeah it was incredible you
know i'm a 10 year old kid well you go
what my god muhammad ali would be over
there we've got teacher muhammad ali
over there uh you know and so many
people loved magic that went on to do
many different things and
magic you know
really the idea of dreaming and the idea
of the impossible and discovering
discovering new
ways of thinking really informed a lot
of art across across the world who was
the first person
do you remember your formative
experience with that with being struck
by magic and the power of magic when you
were a kid do you remember the first
time you were dazzled by something
you know for me
uh like everybody i was searching for a
way to fit ins you know what can i do
with my world and you know i swung the
baseball bat and you know the ball went
that way
that way david is referencing the out of
bounds sides
now i'm referencing the fact that i
sucked yeah you know that's sports
so
you know i said what am i going to do
and you know i started with
ventriloquism
you know throwing my voice and i was i
was bad at that too
that led me that led me to magic and
magic with puppets then david you had a
puppet that you attempted to do it with
yeah i still have it and it's it's in
the actually in the museum yeah i was a
big fan of paul winchell you know the
name paul winchell yes he was the voice
of tigger oh my god i loved him he does
a lot of great voices
yes look at him go that's right exactly
and that was you're just using
knucklehead which is one of his
characters
um yeah but uh him and jerry mahoney is
his puppet knucklehead smith and but i
loved it he was a brilliant brilliant
creator he created
the artificial heart for example he
invented the artificial heart uh he
invented the disposable razors you're
kidding yeah yeah but he was a great
voice guy and a ventriloquist an actor
amazing well i love this guy and i
wanted to be him but i couldn't be him
because i didn't have that skill but it
led me to magic which i got for some
reason i was good at and i was inventing
magic very very young
like how young david and were you doing
with like kids at school how did that
who were your first audiences it was at
school my family my friends and uh but
it came very easy to me i would go to
the magic or the library in my local
library and
there'd be this many magic books on the
shelf in this section david's making it
just like about a foot long so there
weren't a lot of very small sections
that's right um
yeah i gotta remember we're not well i
forget myself i know i know it's so
ideal yeah thank you for the reminder i
i think i really uh would take out the
magic book and i'd read the
the the effect what the audience would
see
but i wouldn't
turn the page to real then reveal the
method i wouldn't learn the method i try
to guess the method
and try to
you know deduct what would will be the
technology behind it and i started
inventing new magic by doing that and
again i was bad at everything else but
magic for some reason i was good at and
when i was 12 i invented a piece of
magic that was in
a very important magic book called the
tarbell course in magic which was um
a whole series of books from the 1920s
that they kept upgrading throughout the
years and um yeah it was a big honor to
have a 12 year old 12 years old yeah
yeah
what was the trick
it was called it was called mento pen it
was a mind reading trip with a pen where
the pen would allow you to read people's
minds oh wait i'm going to get a pen
i'm going to see if
you need one of those that's a very
important part of this uh but um
i invented it in french class
because
my wife is french
ironically i learned no french so i
can't speak any french well you were too
busy with tricks uh yeah something like
that but but i i loved um this idea and
i it was the first introduction to to
my creation of magic this mento pen it's
okay it still kind of works they're
they're putting it out again as an
actual thing to buy but
but it's a lot of fun what's the idea
behind it david curie and how did it
come to you
i was in french class really bored um
and i was looking at this flare pen and
i had a property about it that had kind
of a magic principle which i can't
reveal okay but that magic principle uh
said well i can make something out of
this that can amaze people with it and
there was a selection of
uh
a number between one and four and you'd
know
what the spectator chose and that was it
but um yeah
and i still don't speak french
even with a french wife she hasn't
taught you anything even angry words not
a french wife or french daughter
do they so your daughter must be
bilingual
get in there yeah wow and when she's
very upset with you does she say like
zutala i mean there are
certain i haven't heard that one but
okay well that's good that's a good sign
no but they they do speak a little
french together so
i didn't learn enough french to learn
the secret talk oh they can talk about
you a little code that's that's funny
what david was was the initially was it
the
was it the effect that it would have on
people what was it the uh act of
the the reaction that these tricks these
magic tricks would have on people was
that part of the
the poll was that part of the
cs i think
we all do what kind of
uh gets us acceptance right yeah were
you funny as a kid are you funny
hilarious
uh i i think i think i cultivated that
because i was so tiny i've talked about
this a lot i was i was very short very
tiny and um i kind of it was a way to
yeah like you said fit in and and be
seen
um and it was i loved comedy i loved
laurel and hardy and the marx brothers i
i just loved
making people laugh and so i i asked
because i do remember um that having an
effect on me you know getting that kind
of acceptance and getting a reaction
from people i think there's a real
important thing about getting acceptance
you know as a parent now
uh you know you kind of think back to
that time and how important what how you
react to your kids or react to other
people
what you give them the gift you give
them by your honest response to what
they're doing and for me you know
certainly when i got a positive response
because you know as kids you get a lot
of negative response right people like
really want to put you down sure it's
magic was my way and um and if you're
kind of good at it i mean you're good at
comedy and theater and so forth i uh i
was good at magic so yeah that made me
special yeah um
i think
there was a story you know when i was 12
years old there was a birthday party i
think maybe 10 years old it was a
birthday party i did all my magic stuff
for all the kids at my birthday party my
own party yeah and uh this is a horrible
story but uh but i can't wait yes it's
really uh really is shocking um
it made me special i did all this stuff
my mother themed the party with little
uh
magician uh cutouts on the tables and
you know displays was all kind of themed
my mother's pretty crafty and i did my
little show and everybody applauded and
i put my all my stuff
the stuff that made me special into a
drawer in my room
and uh
10 minutes later my cousins without me
knowing went into the drawer
and pulled out all the stuff
saw how everything worked it kind of was
dancing around them look we now have a
workstation like this
it was devastating
it was a really bad moment even the
cousins today uh you know who are still
you know in their 50s or something they
go we're really sorry david
it was really horrible
and it's like because that's what made
me special yeah yeah oh my god you must
have been it was destroyed but it shows
you how important uh you know the things
that you find that give you value yeah
you know yeah sure and and you have to i
learned from that obviously there is a
lock on all my magic drawers now oh my
gosh
um but but when even the one you you
were talking about the referencing the
pen one
those are secrets you don't want to give
up i mean that makes you yeah but you go
out of your way and then you work hard
to keep creating new things because you
know
today on the internet if you look up how
i do my stuff
there's a lot of revealed secrets and a
lot of those things is me
making making videos that are not real
to misguide people oh so
a lot of people
so people come up to me and say i saw on
you know on the internet shows how you
do your thing yeah i know i did it it's
my kind of misdirection oh that's funny
so it's that's in it's uh it's a magic
trick in and of itself is to
yeah distract from the actual magic
that's interesting
so but so that what must have been how
do you
how do you then recover from something
like how do you go back and regain
uh whatever it was about that that made
that felt special to you that separated
you it's it's um
you talk about the birthday party yeah
yeah well i think what i did was you
know you have sorrow for a while abject
sorrow
um then at the time i wasn't inventing
stuff so i you know i try to get my
parents to take me back to new york and
buy more stuff
but i think just
even today when i invent illusions and
people do the illusions people copy it
yeah there's a guy there's a guy in
france really popular guy in france
basically doing my show in vegas he
comes here he comes to the show and he
has a little uh he writes down
everything i say and do the music
choices all that and literally does a
show big broadway show in spain
exact it's my show oh stories
and so what do you do you just keep
going you know you i fortunately have
the ability to create new things so you
know
imagine if you know
somebody came to broadway with with that
all the songs are west side story
and they claimed it as theirs
exactly it's a twist it's a twist yeah
it's just different enough um wow so do
you but then you think like i mean it is
a slippery slope because everything's
derivative i mean that is west side
story is derivative of romeo and juliet
you know the marx brothers begats woody
allen woody whatever uh but but to to
copy precisely is a whole other level of
i mean that falls into some separate
category that would be very upsetting to
me if somebody came and just
studied my moves you know yeah yeah um
and they just see him there do you do
are you i don't i don't know him but
people send me emails and all that stuff
and it's like it makes me sad but also
sort of after the sadness and the
frustration
it's very motivating too yeah yeah
i'm a luckily able to write another song
you know metaphorically speaking yeah i
am ready to you find you find the the
motivation to keep going and that i
guess that helps the art well it must be
strange too because you struck me as a
very obviously creative person and um
and so much of the joy in in doing it
for me anyway is is just in that is in
the process of doing it is in creating
it so um i don't know how much joy i
would get from just um you know aping
another
person's work but that's just me i don't
know maybe that the reaction it's funny
because magic the reaction is so strong
from the audience
it takes a lot of work to copy it it
does take work because you have to build
it and create you know right magic is
not like music uh not like
you know we have to create the new piano
each time the technologies we create
each time
so if i have a new idea for things i can
sometimes use something that
technology that existed but in most
cases the technology has to be recreated
new so for somebody to do that takes
work to copy what i'm doing yeah
but um
yeah i mean it's it's it's not positive
when it happens yeah but
but uh it does you have to find the
kind of the the golden and the gold is
is is to keep going yeah yeah yeah who
were your heroes growing up who were the
guys that you
would put in your museum as being like
real inspirations well my magic
inspirations i'll talk about in a second
you know my story personal story is that
i was good at inventing magic and
performing it i people liked what i was
doing i found a unique way of doing it
because my idols really weren't other
magicians my real idols were frank
sinatra and fred astaire and gene kelly
victor fleming the film director orson
welles who i got to meet and he hosted
one of my specials uh francis ford
coppola uh people that were storytellers
uh with their music or dancing or in the
cinema people that did that that really
were the people i looked up to
i knew enough about magic but those are
the people that formed my
you know who who i am and my magic
really reflected it my magic was about
storytelling uh yeah
it was about
doing things that
was
you know cinematic uh and uh and very
very different than other magicians now
that said in this museum and in this
book it's about the magicians
i also knew about them i was friendly
with a lot of them
um uh and i've got rooms full of their
amazing things channing pollock was an
inspiration to me uh because of the
perfection of what he did he looked
great he became a film star for a while
and he was alive during my lifetime so i
got to meet him he was a guy that super
handsome produced dubs you can google
him channing pollock they call him the
most handsome man in the world and he's
a handsome name
chanting politicians are often handsome
yeah that's true right um he didn't have
the body he didn't have a magic mic
thing going on but
he was a great looking guy and a very
skilled magician there was a guy named
ricciardi who was a
one of my
heroes not because he invented magic
because he didn't invent anything really
new magically
but the way he performed it was amazing
and um
his skill he was kind of a bull fighter
kind of guy and
was very powerful he was
gene kelly good as a performer you know
um
and where the other magicians were not
they had different
some were funny some were good and i
tried to get a little bit of all of that
in my career to try to to be somebody
that people liked hopefully you know i'm
still working on that part um
pretty well there and um and you know
and do things that were inventions that
were they could move the art forward
right um there was another guy named
robert houder in who dan
was called the father of modern magic
and he took magic off the street uh and
dressed like the sophisticated person
and did a show that of his inventions
basically it was automatons the first
robots that existed uh he invented um
mystery clocks which are still used
today to tell time
with a hand that's just suspended hand
to tell actually tell the time really
remarkable and a very inspirational guy
um that
uh it you know pushed me forward to
invent more magic and to kind of
recreate what had been done before in a
new way and these are all detailed of
course in the book in history of magic
oh um and and did you ever get to know
ricky j was he somebody that you're
familiar with this museum in fact was
he was a steward of this museum for many
many years
uh and uh eventually the person that
actually was the owner had some legal
problems with with financial legal
problems so they had to sell it and they
sold it to me um and uh so i've been
it's become four times that size it was
the mulholland library
of conjuring arts uh back then john
mulholland worked for the cia was hired
by the cia as a magician to use magic
technology and magic principles to uh to
use an espionage and uh in stopping
crime and so forth so magic is has been
used in wars magic technique has been
used for different deception techniques
and uh
camouflage techniques that magician
would understand has been used in
wartime and espionage and during the
cold war and mulholland was one of the
people that helped the cia did do that
kind of kind of thing
his library i should say yeah was
half of houdini's library was his
library houdini gave half of his library
to the library of congress and half of
his library to john mulholland
that mahon library i have so i have half
of houdini's library now oh my god and
the other half is in the
library uh of congress so it's pretty
cool yeah that is really cool do you how
often do you so you're able to just
pull up houdini one of houdini's
personal books off the shelf many
thousands of them and wow we've
acquired many libraries around the world
in english library holland library and
combine them together to this amazing
amazing archive the uh i have 8 000
duplicate books
duplicate books it's incredible so this
place is a kind of the smithsonian of
magic and all my friends
yeah it's an amazing thing and how can
people go there david what's that like
it's difficult because it's so many
secrets are here and everything is not
behind glass so what i do is i uh i do
exhibitions outside of the museum i'll
take exhibitions out of this and bring
it to new york and bring it to la so
people can actually see things without
hurting uh the craft of what i do so you
would have to know you personally you'd
have to like make friends with you you'd
have to say come on somebody's podcast
get to know them a little bit in a
public way and then form a friendship
off the podcast
get invited we do you're totally welcome
exactly but uh but we do tours for
scholars for the press we do
you know maybe 50
or
100 tours a year uh through here but
they're private tours that have to be
taken eight people at a time through
here and but i do try to share it i do
try to take exhibitions out of here the
book is the perfect way of doing a tour
okay museum so there's the pitch this is
a personal tour via the the pages of the
book but you'll see pictures of it's an
amazing amazing place it is fascinating
and and what i'm seeing just a glimpse
that i'm seeing i wish people could see
this uh how eclectic and
uh
beautifully eclectic the background
looks here all the little like
tchotchkes and
that's what you can call them chocolates
that you know make
gigantic things vanish and and
and decapitate people and re make them
back again too they survive it you
know it's not like this it's the squid
game you know there's actually a happy
ending yeah i haven't seen it yet so
thanks for the spoiler alert
[Music]
native deodorant is made with
ingredients you've heard of like coconut
oil oh that was christian getting his
native deodorant oh you have two ones
there oh yeah those are my favorites i
also like i found the lavender you know
oh the lavender is good this one i've
been really into lately the eucalyptus
mint but i'm telling you i'm really into
this lavender they're a bunch that are
they're they all work that's the crazy
thing about this oh they keep you
smelling fresh all day they last all day
i've tried so many of these natural i'm
sure you have as well making the switch
to an aluminum free deodorant it does
not mean you have to sacrifice on
performance native will keep you it does
keeps you smelling and feeling fresh all
day long besides the classic deodorant
native offers an unscented option and a
baking soda free formula for those with
sensitivities so if you want to try
cutting down on your plastic use
native even has a deodorant made of 100
paper board packaging amazing check out
the over 15 000 five star reviews from
happy customers who switch to native
you're going to love native as much as i
do i'm pretty confident in that right
now you can save 20
on your first purchase go to native
do dot com slash long or
use promo code long at checkout that's
native do deo yeah now if that wasn't
clear dot com slash long or use promo
code long at checkout to save 20
on your first purchase
are you having trouble sleeping i am
rather i was how did you alleviate that
trouble oh i'll tell you it's easy c
b
d plus cbd it's a daily use plus cbd
they're sleep gummies yeah and they help
you get rest so you can wake up feeling
focused and refreshed that's right i was
concerned that because you know
sometimes some sleep aids can make you
feel weird the next morning a little
froggy yeah not these these make you
feel i you saw me last night how calm
did i see you did you seemed relieved
and calm you were having fun though
still you weren't like out of it are
these formulated by like amateurs and
people who are just getting into no no
no quite the opposite they're formulated
by a team of medical experts and doctors
the plus cbd sleep gummies taste great
delicious actually it's like a treat
before you go to bed and they're made
with award-winning cbd combined with
melatonin magnolia bark and lemon balm
which is i think your favorite kind of
bomb i love all bombs but that is my
favorite so sleep better tonight by
visiting plus cbd oil
dot com and enter promo code long for 40
off your order that's code long at plus
cbd oil dot com
for 40 off
[Music]
people must think of you as how i do as
having this um because of your ability
to do this they must think of you as
having a
an almost like super human-like power
like a dif a power that's all true it's
all true okay well that's what i was
wondering and uh thanks for being so
blunt and honest
uh i just agreed with you yes
but they do they must right i mean no i
can't approach you differently i think
magic um
i'm so fortunate to get technology
before anybody else sees it i've got so
many friends that are futurists and uh
you know physics people and
and and scientists and i get to see the
stuff in the beginning
i get to incorporate that into my work
so there's so much technology and magic
and
i get to use it and historically you'll
see in the book
people who read minds you'll see how
they read minds and a lot of this is
technology that didn't exist that people
didn't know existed back then you know
imagine for example imagine a little
buddha
and inside was a speaker inside the
buddha and nobody knew
what a speaker was
so
you were going back to the 1920s speaker
existed but not commonly known
and
so you have a card selected nine of
diamonds
and
and the person who was on the other end
of the speaker would know it's night of
diamonds by
and you'd have the spectator remember
the nine of diamonds and the spectator
walk up to that buddha
and they said put your ear next to it
the buddha would say
people would freak out
i mean they just like they'd lose it
because how sorcery is this
yeah so the point is that
you know that was technology that people
didn't know about and so this thing's in
my show currently that that uh five
years from now i won't be able to do
very sure
but i get to use it for now and in the
process of it actually i'm inventing and
with a wonderful team inventing new
technology that's going to be useful
someday i get to keep it for a while and
hold on to it yeah but eventually it'll
get out there and and it'll be in your
home
uh robert hudan the name i mentioned
before
i think invented the first smart home
in his home in the 1840s you know you'd
knock at the door and the door would
open mysteriously
with the
electric principles and he'd know how
many people walked through the door well
now it's every grocery store opens up
the doors but that started as a magic
effect that was a piece of magic
um on conan i used to do a thing a
parody of me where a guy kind of with my
old my old haircut would like gesture a
door and it would open up or they would
go up to a garage and the garage would
open up and he'd make a thing like that
but that's it it was it was meant as a
joke but it was actually a real thing
you know those things were magic effects
to start with
and now they're well common i wonder if
you've seen neil befriended the show uh
neil patrick harris's home in new york
have you been there the one in harlem
i've i've not big fan of his he's such a
talented guy oh he i'm shocked that he
hasn't like nerded out on you i'm
shocked that he hasn't accosted you yeah
a long time ago he's welcome back it's
grown four times the size since oh wow
he was here yeah yeah oh i bet um well
he's in his home somebody has his home
well similar i mean like you were that
you were describing to who dan's who dan
a lot of little you know he's got hidden
doors and um there are tricks the house
is like kind of all like literally
tricked out uh and and has this kind of
gothic or maybe kind of more victorian
feel but he's it's it's the closest that
i've seen to what i'm looking at right
now but now you know but remember
imagine take that same stuff
and go a hundred years ago right oh my
god people must start religions you can
start religions with it it's like
some people did actually
yeah they take advantage of it
i bet yeah well again people who aren't
familiar or don't consider that aspect
of it the
technological aspect they must be
um
really
thrown by you they they must have an odd
reaction you must see a part of just
just i mean socially you must see a part
of human behavior that is
unlike what other people glimpse they
i'm sure often they may even be afraid
of you do you ever get stranger
i mean like really overwhelmed by you
and and consider you
know if you look back at old magic
posters which plenty of them are in this
book by the way um
they're really beautiful incredible um
they're all very mysterious yeah and
kind of like you know i'm a sinister
there's a sinister element a little bit
or i'm smarter than you idea that idea
i'm smarter than you which is you know
when you start getting reactions from
magic you kind of
uh
there isn't you have to think for a
second you know do i want to kind of
take advantage of this yeah but i found
you know in my in my career i've always
been very welcoming i've always been
part of you know part of the people you
know um and uh i dress
not in costumes but i dress like a you
know everyone else dresses on the street
i think it makes them it makes the magic
stronger because i'm i'm relatable yeah
and i think you know all my stories are
not about the far east or or india or
the princess karnak it's all about you
know my girlfriend at the time you know
believing me or or or not i remember
them there being like a sexual element
too i mean i remember seeing them when i
was a kid so like pretty much everything
had a sexual element when you're at a
certain age but like there was a very
there was a real like romanticism about
them and like uh of the time you know
the time of my work by the time it was
mtv right wasn't it it was all of that
so it was all about you know the
relationships and kind of and everybody
started doing that so i had to kind of
stop that now it's about family which is
more about where i'm at now so it became
from that very romantic and very sensual
kind of
uh
thing around it that story became more
about family and having kids and my fat
you know losing loved ones and all that
stuff or even childhood dreams you know
my show right now
is about um spaceships i make a
spaceship appear during my show you know
50 foot spaceship you know over their
heads are dinosaurs trying you know
trying to change the language of magic
it's not card tricks for me it's about
dinosaurs and spaceships and time travel
and aliens all those things that hadn't
been uh part of my world so that was
where i had been going with it but
though it might seem
obviously it's much on a much bigger
scale and more fantastical does it still
incorporate the same elements of those
card tricks i don't want to call them
basic but the ones that
you know that people like i'm sure you
you mastered when you were younger and
ricky j of course was so good
do they still is it still those
principles
you know
i've really made an effort to
invent new principles
i really tried to look forward um
because uh for the art to move forward
there is
a kind of a willingness to keep doing
the same stuff with a new
wrapping around it or a new paint job on
the thing and for me that was very
unrewarding for me yeah um so the method
for uh
vanishing an airplane that i did a
million years ago you know that was a
new method that didn't exist or you know
or the the flying thing that i used to
fly around and based on some old things
but taken in a very very different
direction you know
so
although it has roots in the beginning
the actual piano has been rebuilt you
know so i'm i'm composing on different
on different uh
a different equipment and i think that
that that's and that's really that's
rewarding for me and you know you could
re-replicate and so many people in my
field
do do new versions of what's been done
before i really make an effort to to
have new principles that could uh
hopefully inspire people my business
down the line what do your kids think of
it uh david are they
have you dazzled them or
is it just like a thing that dad does i
think you know
obama said
something that made me very happy
i'm not sure it's his quote but he said
it anyway says you're never a prophet in
your own home
and that gives me a lot of strength
yeah my kids are great that mike i've
got great kids and they're you know they
have interest in
in theater and science and that stuff
and uh
not really great interest in what i'm
doing which is which is which is fine
yeah and i'm not that person to try to
push somebody in my business and you
know magic you know some of magic came
from circus and the circus world right
um you you knew you were going to do the
family's thing you know i'm friendly
with some of the the wallenda kids
and you know no kidding
yeah you know
they knew as a kid they're going to do
this no matter what and um certainly
that wasn't my upbringing my father
wanted me i wanted to be an actor
and uh
you know so when i started doing magic
he was very supportive except it's kind
of living his dream in a way yeah yeah
yeah defeat us and he opened the men's
clothing store um to do
that gave up
new jersey mccordy's corby's mens shop
and me touching new jersey and then
warren new jersey but that which we've
also recreated here
in my place so it kind of really tells
my story how cool i know i know what you
mean david because my mother was a
bearded woman and she wanted me to go
into that
field um
yeah mine i i can't grow facial hair
though um
what did so did your dad do that's
interesting that he wanted to be now
what what form did that take would he do
like community theater he did community
theater you know out of the army um
the army air corps he uh was going to go
to
aada american academy of dramatic arts
because you can go there for free
but uh my mom said you gotta you gotta
eat so
you know yeah she was she oh yeah she
prioritized uh survival yeah um
what a buzzkill uh how often do you you
must be sick of answering this but i'm
curious how often tricks go wrong how
often illusions go wrong or they
something happens you have to redirect
the illusion yeah i have
multiple
endings to most everything i do
so if it goes in a bad direction i'm
usually able to give the audience an
experience that is satisfying
it's not satisfying for me because i
want them to see a certain thing yeah
but at least it gets me out of trouble
and it goes wrong a lot actually you
know yeah last night in the show
you know
there was a preset that wasn't done
quite right so the audience saw kind of
half half of an illusion it wasn't so
good
and um you know nothing to do with me
um celine dion in her show if a lighting
queue is wrong they say she's a great
singer and did you notice lighting queue
uh yeah it's okay
i'm not sure or if barbra streisand is
on stage and a piece of scenery falls
they say the scenery fell but she was a
was it great
yeah with with me if something was the
lighting queue wrong goes wrong and
right to you and it goes yeah i'm a bad
magician so that is a man you know
having to be cute and funny and and and
you know personable knowing that
absolute terror is going to come behind
you is an interesting thing to deal with
every day
and you know you look at the world
differently i mean i bet i you know i
walk into a room i know where the exit
signs are i know i just i see you know
in school they used to put thumbtacks in
our chairs the kids would put thumbtacks
in the chairs so i'm trained to put my
hand in a seat before i sit down i'm
trying you know i'm trained to an
awareness of awareness yeah we have a
program called the project magic which
is uh using magic in hospitals and it's
really great and when you're in
hospitals you meet a lot of patients
that have
you know been there because for for
cause they they they made a mistake and
one of the common mistakes in therapy is
an unsee un seat belted person who's had
a head trauma because of not having a
seat belt
well you see enough of that that what's
the first thing you do when you own a
car
man it goes boom it goes on it's
automatic it's like it's part of who you
are so all of that prep comes from a
little bit of fear a little bit i bet if
spirit of fear is okay it's okay and you
know i just i that seep it goes on i
look at the seat before i sit down
i go on stage and i look at all my
presets to make sure that the least
amount of bad is going to happen
it's really training as far as that i
once i once did uh the mike douglas show
remember mike douglas showing your kid
uh no mike bullard i'm thinking okay
mike douglas show is a very very popular
show from philadelphia and everybody did
the show i mean uh
they were they had co-hosts of the show
um uh john lennon was a host for a week
um i you know i i was maybe 22 i guess i
had a bad week they put me as a co-host
for you believe it or not but you know
john lennon was weak before then david
copperfield it was ridiculous but on
that show well what's wrong with that i
could see you hosting a show you'd be
you're right no i was the co-host but
anyway the point is that on the show
that i was on they had lucille ball and
james james stewart as what yes yeah
they had the biggest guest like this oh
my god you so you had to you interviewed
them no no no well kind of mike douglas
did most of the interview i was just
kind of a i was the ed mcmahon of the
show that week anyway the point is that
is that about ed mcmahon yeah oh yeah
but less pressure to be at mcmahon
way less
yes
yeah um and uh i've got a check for you
okay yeah exactly you just present
novelty checks that's right
so what happened was lucia ball on the
show
you know watched me do my little
performance that i did
and she said to me you know
we did so much physical comedy on i love
lucy
that i would always she's talking she
would always set her own props david
always set your own props
and you know she had a gigantic dizzy
luth you know studio staff
but she set her own props because you
know i get it but to your question you
know do things wrong the answer is yes
and what do you do to to be safe about
it you you kind of go through all the
plan b's possible you know last night's
show i had no plan b we just kept going
it was the solution they already saw
less of an effect
but uh because there was no out for that
as an example but a lot of things i have
have ways you can't sweat you can't show
that you're sweating i mean you i swear
i swear you sweat yeah yeah but see
that's the that's where the acting comes
into play i mean like you're that's how
you and your dad must have been so proud
of you for many things but like
specifically you had mentioned you know
his love of acting and that to me is
like how do you manage that anxiety
that's a performance that's pure
performance yeah was there a time where
you couldn't recover where it was just
um
it went off the rails and yet to come up
with something totally different the
only time the show stopped of note is
when i cut my finger off on stage oh my
god people thought it was an illusion
it's yeah it's a story that i've told
before but you know i was on stage doing
a thing with a very sharp pair of
scissors and a a piece of rope and a
woman on stage and i would cut the rope
and restore it the whole sequence we did
you can see it on youtube
but one night i was not looking and i
cut the whole tip of my finger off
oh god and it was sitting on the tip my
finger was sitting on the blade of the
scissors and blood and blood was
everywhere
my god and i said to the audience
ladies and gentlemen i cut my finger off
and they started to applaud
of course of course they thought it was
part of the show
oh my god and you know i don't like
blood all that much but they took me off
stage and they took me to the hospital
and they found mike tyson's cut man
no
his his plastic surgeon sewed my finger
back on
um same one who did his ear
uh i think he he's the one that did
somebody else's oh that's right evander
holyfield right that's right he
yeah so um no yeah so maybe he used that
same cut man i don't know for how he
feels
i got a great guy don't worry about it
wow that's
wild yeah so they sewed it back
they put the whole tip back on yeah do
you have any is there any residual like
weirdness about it no it's nice good job
yeah i can't tell i'm looking at all
your friends there there's a god you
know
let's grow back that's a real illusion i
go heal heal you know
i called ernest angeli
well you know funny enough david people
probably think
a lot of people probably think you have
those abilities but
obviously i don't claim i have any
abilities yeah all right because it's
all you know technique technology it's
it's it's it's invention it's it's all
that
but you know there are parts of the
world that they think it's real you know
of course
and uh i was um
before i went to russia
um
there were people picketing outside the
theater
from
religious groups because they thought i
was demonic or something like oh
my god yeah and you know and if you look
i'm smiling i'm kind of you know kind of
cute in the pictures and you know how do
you possibly think them um
but um but they did
and they were going to shut us down
and
the church there i went to the kremlin
actually
to a dinner
the day before the shows opened
and um
gosh i'm going to get messed up the the
hats their looks like spades those big
tall religious hats would that be a
cardinal or a what kind of religious
leader would that be um i don't know in
the in the russian orthodox i don't know
it must be like it was it was russian
orthodox you're correct
and the guy i walked into this dinner
and he was there kind of the leader of
the church
and he looks me over and i smile at him
and he gives me the thumbs up like this
wow
or russian orthodox church means you
were going to hell
he was pointing up he was pointing his
thumb was up
um but um
but in that moment everything that all
the picketers went away and so forth
like no kidding yeah yeah there's one
there was this way of saying i took care
of this
you're okay you're okay you're a nice
jewish boy it's okay okay
wow wow what does that feel like i i
know what it feels like to be you know
it was scary actually that was scary
i bet i bet people people that angry um
and and for for reasons that are you
know are
ridiculous but they believe it
nonetheless that must be really
wild i think you know yeah humanity is
interesting you know people are going to
believe certain things people are going
to be invested in an idea that they have
and they feel very strongly about that
and in magic that exists and i think you
know i do everything in my power to to
to show that it's a a form of
inspiration of of showing limitless
possibilities and not about anything
that's going to be
uh
something to be scared about yeah sure
um
david when you were researching this
book did you
uh i did i'm sure you learned a lot but
did were there any like wild revelations
that you had um that really just
amazed you uh in
in so far as like the history of magic
100 there's
people have
amazing stories you know and i
took over the museum uh and then started
to make it grow
and multiply
you know in the beginning i didn't
really get it i was always looking
forward in magic i was i knew enough
about old magic principles i was always
looking forward to inventing new things
and when i acquired it i didn't
understand really why i was getting it i
didn't know have any historical
yearning for magic history but then i
started really looking to the stories of
these people and they all had the same
situations as me the same kind of
challenges uh there's
there's people in the museum that that
have done amazing things contributions
to society george melies who if you saw
the movie hugo wonderful scorsese movie
hugo is about melias
who really helped invent cinema
storytelling cinema
you wouldn't have a job uh justin if if
you didn't if a magician well you would
have a job in live theater but the
movies were created by uh
technology of making things appear uh
trains going or pastoral scenes
but it was a magician george melissa
decided to tell stories
yeah with that medium and to tell
cinderella or trip to the moon
and all those things started as a magic
effect in a magic show and uh the
storytellers adopted it because a
magician said we're going to tell
stories with this magic effect
of
of the cinema you know you know he the
trip to the moon uh the moon the the
rocket landing the the man in the moon's
face
seventy years later we landed on the
moon
seven years later and i i really believe
that seeing things visualized
prototyping the future really helps us
make them real you know and so much in
my work and my show is about
you know redefining what humanity is
going to do in the future
and to try to dream big so that
smarter people than me will be in the
arts kids will be in the united states
you know maybe we could figure out a way
of making that happen for real
dinosaurs
cloning dinosaurs exactly it might
happen
thanks to you
you never know but no i think really we
talk about time travel and you know uh
and and and
and i'm you know i'm working with some
really amazing uh particle physicists
today i mean just amazing to really make
some of these things happen for real
david how do you reach out to them i
mean are they i mean obviously they're
aware of you as a public figure a very
known person but how is it that you come
into contact with these people these
these innovators i do a lot of begging
okay
um it's a good magic trick and uh no i
think
they
understand
the fact that it starts with an idea it
starts with a dream yeah da vinci
um
drew a bunch of airplanes the
helicopters yeah they didn't really work
but they were beautifully done and the
seed was there right it took 400 years
from that da vinci
airplane idea to the wright brothers
yeah taking off for a few seconds 400
years so i think planting the seed is
very very important having those ideas
to plant a seed
is very very valuable and then time
passes and finally we figure out how to
get it just right and we're seeing it
now imagine
we're taking spaceships and rockets and
landing them back on earth upright
is that that's a magic effect it's
incredible we're seeing that happen now
you know and
you know what we did with landing on the
moon
60 years ago uh you know now we're
starting to progress more we're starting
to get going again with this you know it
took a space race a competition with the
russians to get us to really get to that
right that really innovate yeah so so
does um having such a an intimate
understanding of this of how these
illusions work this this how to
incorporate this technology um into
these fantastical things that you do
has that made you um
more of a believer in the supernatural
in in uh hereafter let's say or in the
beyond or um or is it the opposite is it
is it you you are more beholden to the
practicality of life
you know it's interesting because i um
i
i should be a skeptic and most of my
friends in science are real skeptics
yeah you know skeptics even of
the flying saucers that we've been
seeing you know
yeah
my my friends who are literally genius
geniuses are skeptical of that you know
um but there is many ways to explain you
know things that we see and most of my
science
associates are very skeptical i i'm a
very unusual person in the sense that i
i take great comfort in uh belief you
know belief in in god and kind of yeah
you know i take comfort and i kind of
like it uh and and um
so i kind of want to believe that and a
lot of you know that's very different
from the people who are uh in the in
this science and uh
physics category uh of it but i do take
great
pleasure and you know uh
oprah asked me
once on a episode uh do you believe and
you know
i have these on i've got i have some
islands in the bahamas that that uh is a
resort that we we put together and um
and
i have two cans there that uh reproduce
and you look at these little baby
toucans
and then an hour later they'll be
sprouts like straws that come out and an
hour later they'll be feathers
it's it's like really like
okay yeah it's it's evolution and
science and and uh and uh you can be
explained away but the way it happens is
really
you know quite breathtaking and quite
quite um
kind of supernatural and
ungodly and godly yeah right right right
that was always my favorite argument my
my there was an argument called the
teleological argument for the existence
of god which was which is aquinas
believed and a lot of these great things
really but it was it was an argument by
design it was the idea that like the
design the intricacy of the universe is
could only have been created by
some higher power that was
um just so beautifully put together you
know i
i think logically it's probably
problematic
but
personally i kind of
enjoy yeah the hope of it all you know i
i do enjoy it
um speaking of that uh
what is what would be a good time for me
to come to the islands uh and and stay
there for a little bit
we can get back to this
uh the islands that you have in the
caribbean tomorrow let's go okay great
um i think i've actually been near them
uh seeing them um
uh how
that must have been a dream that must
have been one of those moments in your
life where like i have an island in the
caribbean yeah
it's you know i saw it as an opportunity
for me an opportunity to create it's an
amazing palette to have
yeah you know i've actually have i hate
this sounds bad i have 11 islands a
little little islands
yeah so one i'm going to make a haunted
island right oh wow why not haunt an
island right uh one uh you know
one is going to be an island that's
going to be like beach blanket bingo you
know uh like the old uh frankie avalon
and that furniture yeah yeah that might
be a
that might be a potentially problematic
island i the haunted island you might
have an easier time with
um i'd like to go to both though yeah
exactly but it's it's called mushaki and
the islands of copperfield bay
and it's an amazing place it's like
it's a great place for me to create new
new things in a
non-theatrical but not in a non-theater
way so we do treasure hunts there that
are spectacular treasure hunts we do
james bond experiences there which is
just great yeah
is this open to the is that near where
they shot that james bond movie is that
what am i thinking of the
actually no you're you're right there is
thunderball grotto in the bahamas yes
which is an amazing cave you can snorkel
to that's about i've been there i've
snorkeled there yeah
we're 20 minutes south of there on a
boat
oh wow and it's a it's a place that
people take over uh one group at a time
family takes over it's not hotel rooms
you can rent um but you know it's a
place that a lot of famous people have
uh gone there for it's covert free
that's good it's a little bubble oh yeah
so that's that's a good thing how cool
yeah so so you're still working on those
i mean you're going to use those as like
that's like a future project well no
it's a place that people go to and you
know
sergey brin got married there on the
sandbar
uh
at the penelope cruise and javier bardem
got married there
uh but their whole group they take it
over 24 people at a time
but it's an opportunity for me to create
new things and right now yeah doing all
that it's it's fun i wanted to ask you
about the two cans do you raise the two
cans there i mean are they just part of
the island yeah yeah yeah yeah wow we
have tortoises aldabra tortoises oh my
god i love aldabra
it's amazing you have aldabra tortoises
yeah not it's not a competition i was
lucky enough to go to necker island and
i remember he had uh branson had aldabra
tortoises yeah yeah
wow yeah
richard branson is fantastic he's great
and very inspirational to me you know i
love everything he does and you know our
version our island is is similar in in
many ways because it's a takeover island
yeah yeah but it's also
what i've done is i i put what i do
in on my place is very theatrical and
i've got houdini's pool table in the
game room oh my god and we have uh our
gym is the jack johnson gym base then
the uh amazing fighter from the turn of
the century and
we've made everything has a real soul to
it that's uh so my unique take on that
have you finished the haunted island yet
no still working on it still working oh
boy how fun how cool um did houdini died
from getting hit in the stomach is that
an uh urban legend that's right that's
correct it is true huh yeah yeah he got
hit in the stomach uh when he wasn't
ready and uh
a kind of appendicitis began and uh he
died on halloween which is pretty good
promotion right pretty good yeah for
halloween too
[Music]
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wandery app
[Music]
[Music]
what is your most commonly used emoji
thumbs up
yeah by far by far classic uh if you
could be a professional athlete what
sport would you play and why
boy the lightning is slowing down
well you had mentioned you weren't let
me think
what would it be i think i'd like to be
a great swimmer okay yeah
snack food what's your favorite snack
food snap p crisps
oh great promotion for them yes i love
those a movie that you loved growing up
one of your favorite movies growing up
that you wanted to introduce to your
kids well i did a lot and i forced them
to watch all these movies i
it's easy wizard of oz
obviously uh gone with the wind although
it's pretty problematic today same
director victor fleming a big fan
harold and maude
what and the producers love the
producers uh i have the actual script
from the producers where it says
springtime for hitler and they crossed
out hitler and they wrote mel brooks
wrote the producers because they
couldn't use the title springtime for
hitler oh my god that's so which is
great yeah i have um
uh
and and of course you must have loved
movies growing up it still informed
informs what i do and of course the best
movie of all time which is step brothers
oh yes oh my god i love that did we just
become best friends
yeah
yeah um
but uh
it's so funny that you know you watch uh
uh
joaquin phoenix
you know he does he does the joker right
gigantic success with a joker and they
ask him what's your what movie you see
more than anything else he says step
brothers
isn't that funny yeah i know i remember
uh sean penn cornering vince vaughn and
telling him how much he loved wedding
crashers he thought wedding crashers
should have won
the oscar and you know it's funny when
these serious actors um
yeah
yeah uh your go-to karaoke song
oh it's a it would be um sinatra
and it's not your dean martin you're
nobody if
uh you know until somebody loves you
um yeah yeah yeah or or i'm sorry i'm
sorry
uh taxi
taxi okay yeah
uh and and i'm curious because you said
you you had time with orson welles what
that he was he was uh
sounded like almost a mentor to you what
was he like
he's such a fascinating character well i
got to know him pretty well he hosted my
first tv special
and
he wanted to be known as a magician and
he was a very good he actually was a
very good magician if you watch the old
videos from doing stuff
terrific
we have it playing the museum i have
some of his props in the museum
and
he's a chapter in the book
in a special edition that
barnes noble has
but
he was a very very
inspirational guy you know and uh
i um
yeah i mean citizen kane you know yeah
uh just you watch you just go wow you
know every single thing just shows oh
man you know what
you touch aviva exactly and all of the
stuff that that you know as a young
people to just have a bunch of people
with unlimited budget
ish for that time just creating
something really really great i would
have loved to have watched that take
place
greg tolan the cinematographer greg
toland
you know i have a movie that he made uh
a magic movie that he made a little ten
minute thing that greg tolan was a
cinematographer on i used i used it at
my show for a while where i would
interact with a young orson wells
on a film talking back and forth to the
screen you can watch it on the flying my
flying special
and it's great greg tollen is the
cinematographer and um
uh yeah he had a big big impact and you
know i would love to be a film director
of that that um
uh
level you know yeah yeah and he wanted
to be a magician you know really and he
was actually a pretty good magician well
david had you have you considered i know
there's so much film work that goes into
your work and cinematography of course
and but have you ever thought about
directing like a narrative making a
narrative film you seem like you have a
real love for it yeah
it's never too late you know never too
late yeah but i think you know i i was
the director of all my specials my tv
specials yeah and um and uh they got you
know a lot of emmy awards
um
but that was very very very flattering
so you do you know when you try to focus
and do really good work as good as you
possibly do it's nice when people you
know kind of pay attention to it but oh
god you know i would like i would love
to have
it in me too to direct the film
somewhere
some like comedy that people don't
expect like a stepbrothers um who was
who was your very first celebrity crush
um it would have to be annette funicello
okay beach blanket bingo yeah yeah but
before that this is a mickey mouse
so you know uh and
i was
four five and you know she was on tv and
and uh yeah it was
for sure that
uh if you had to get a tattoo david well
i told my kids if they get a tattoo
there's no money in the future for them
so
[Laughter]
okay just for my kids everybody else can
get beautiful tattoos and that's been
something really remarkable there's
people that actually have tattoos of me
yeah is there any justin long tattooed
people i i can't believe i'm saying this
but i've seen it yes there there are
some real horror i did a couple horror
movies that people love and so there are
horror my chara there's a character that
i
i died at the end of one called jeepers
creepers and my eyes are removed it's
really gruesome
and i've seen that tattoo people have
that and it's what do you think i mean
i've had it many times
it is uh
it's both flattering and disturbing it's
like a weird mix of those two what's
disturbing about it what's disturbing uh
that somebody would have
me to go to those lengths would would it
would
um certainly to have my dead image on
them like a dead me
you know i did a horror movie too you
know not quite as good as yours yours
was better i did a movie called terra
train with jamie lee curtis in it oh and
i'm really bad in it don't watch it i
tried okay now i want to see it uh don't
is it that bad
it's beautifully shot john alcock who uh
did the barry lyndon and then oh wow and
and the shining yeah the great
cinematographer he did the movie and
roger sparta
who turned out to be an excellent
director uh did there was his first
movie the territory so i really suck in
it but this really pretty shots of me
they made me look kind of pretty in it
um
but which is the hard work um but alcott
was up to the challenge um but i did um
this movie and i get killed in it too
spoiler alert i don't care don't watch
it i get killed um you know really
mortified um yeah gruesome and luckily
they haven't tattooed me in that
you know that condition of it
but you must be tattooed a you as a
magician you must have seen
a lot lots
isn't it funny
me tattooed and it's the same reaction
exactly your impression of it you know
the flattery is you know it kind of
focus on the flattery but it's like
really you made that decision
i know forever also signatures they do
that with you yes yes you sign my arm
and this arm gets the signature gets
tattooed well there's so much pressure
on that i found a tremendous amount of
pressure
uh what if i mess up this is going to be
permanent this is it
what if i do something that they they
don't like me anymore yeah i know well
uh you're stuck yeah um
how funny how funny david
what is your favorite fruit uh
probably uh it's watermelon fruit
yeah oh god yeah watermelon and
pineapple you know kind of in there
really good for you too um uh and who
would you like to play you in your
biopic the handsomest guy
ever let's see i want okay let's see
that would be tom brady not bad you know
okay
to get some acting lessons you know you
know andrew garfield andrew garfield
could play you i better yeah
whichever and he's terrific right that
wouldn't be bad yeah great actor uh
you'd have to teach him a lot
of illusions um who was your favorite
muppet i'm sure you've worked with the
muppets you know when i was a kid
a friend of mine uh
his name was alan bersky brought me to
see the muppets
uh
i went to see him as a kid i walked into
haha h.a henson associates we walked
this thing yeah and there was the big
like i think maybe snuffleupagus this
giant human bigger than human size thing
in the walking up the stairs to see this
things like
really just one of these enormous
characters i think would have been my my
favorite thing
yeah yeah yeah cool yeah uh makes sense
and and a beatles song a beatles song
that you love that you'd love to hear
right now if you write up bar you go to
the jukebox there's a lot of them you
know that's hard one yesterday
norwegian wood i love that song i once
had a girl or should i say she once said
me
oh god yeah and um your favorite pizza
topping david i think pepperoni
yes yes old-fashioned great it's a
thumbs up um thin crust
yeah okay okay this was such a thrill
for me you gotta come to las vegas come
to the museum i'd love to share with you
for those of you who can't do that one
of the great hanukkah christmas gifts is
this book it's an amazing beautiful
coffee table book very affordable and
i'm really proud of it thank you and i'd
love to see you in vegas i am a huge fan
i was this is such a thrill thank you
thank you bye-bye
[Music]
yeah there's a little bit of um there's
a slight new york i hear a little i mean
even though he grew up in new jersey
it's jersey it's a little like
like
yeah jersey like piscopo a little bit
like uh yeah and also a little bit like
new york jewish um just yeah the hint of
that very surprising that he's jewish no
not surprising that he's jewish but
surprising that he is as accessible i
know as he is i was very very pleasantly
surprised by that you don't both have to
be surprised that david copperfield
should be so down to earth and
accessible
i know because you think of him as oh
he's this big yeah he's this icon but
also like what he does the reason he's
nikon is he's got this show i mean he's
like actually he's like you know such a
performer and and those those specials
that he used to have they were so um
like larger than life i guess
and he had such um
and a mysterious persona and he was just
uh just did not seem like somebody you
could like have an easy fun conversation
right i think i'm a victim of
uh thinking of him too much
by what he does i'm sure a lot of people
are so because of that because i think
of him as this guy who can do magic on
that level i think of him as being like
as a person i know mysterious i know
well that's what i was trying to get
kind of like aloof and weird yeah
but he was like very down to earth and
cool and funny and forthcoming about how
practical a lot of what he does is i
mean all of what he does is it's just uh
it's so much of a science science and
it's
the incorporation of innovation and
technology was that to me was um
how forthcoming he was about that was it
was interesting we were talking about
the magic 8-ball earlier there's
something about
magic in general that it's it's
inherently strange the whole field
because
it's not magic yeah but it's called
magic right and david copperfield is
called a magician
but the truth is
he has access to these secrets like
brilliant things he's created obviously
like i do not mean to diminish it by any
means but
it
it is a trick well you know the whole
thing is a series of tricks which makes
sense that a lot of those great
magicians he talked about that in his
book as well history of magic um that
would be real innovators would be have
invented that guy mulholland invented
things that were very like
common
place now they're very like practical
right because to present a trick too
it's
have you ever met magicians as a kid who
are kind of like strange
seeming and like not so smooth socially
but they just knew how to do with
certain cards yeah it's like they'd
spend a lot of time indoors like
learning right but they so the trick
itself was impressive but the
presentation wasn't necessarily yes he
seems like i mean there's a reason he's
who he is is that his presentation
oh i know he's incredible like i mean
he's such a good
talker and he's very charming very
charming yeah i can see him
just putting on this one-man show he has
that one-man show kind of energy and the
the looks i mean part of it is like a
superficial thing but he's like he's
handsome and he's got this um presence
he's got a real presence and like i
remember when we were kids thinking of
him as like being kind of like a
romantic figure you know that he was
like they're always like women around at
his shows and he was like
wooing them and stuff in the in the
shows i mean there was something there
was like a romantic element he was like
sexual yeah i think he said sensual that
his show had incorporated like a sensual
element but it does it's like yeah i can
see that yeah and like he he wore these
kind of like um
he has yeah i mean you know i know i
want to hear you describe it i just kind
of
failed out well here's what i mean by
sensual
yeah but he then he would reference he
had like a very very slight i don't know
if his insecurity but he kept
referencing that he wasn't like handsome
or he wanted someone handsome to play
him or
um he had a few moments where i was like
what is he talking about he's so
handsome like he yeah he's like famously
happy he is right he hated um famous
models
potty shifter right and i never thought
of him as being like well how did he get
yeah yeah you know
it was like they were sort of like
matched
you know there are and i don't know
everything that dave gabriel and
claudius shift for our match physically
but it's true it's like oh that makes
sense instead of like
whereas like there were other couples
and i don't want to i'm sure people
thought that of me you know so i
shouldn't say but like oh people have
definitely thought that
no offense i think the majority probably
think how did he your own family
yeah i think that of me i don't get how
that guy can just steal his act i don't
i know why does he get that why doesn't
he i would i'd sue him or sue him i know
it's that must be outrageous there's
probably a reason he hasn't so i didn't
want to be negative about it but because
i
would be too like litigious sounding
yeah like you should aware i know but
like truly like that's [ __ ]
crazy crazy he's like hurt by it yeah i
think really affected by it well he
brought it up and he he
i think that's when he related that to
the story when he was a kid and yes
people stole his yes that was a
formative experience for him and it's
still is something that
i'm scared of it must really trigger i
wonder if he has trust issues in life in
general i should have asked him that
yeah well get him on the show
but i wonder if he holds other like
non-magic secrets other secrets
close to the vest
right i wonder
right maybe i mean he must have some
like how do you ask somebody that
probably well to the point where he
well now you're friends with him you
could ask him
yeah um i don't know if you would trust
me if he hears this we shouldn't be
talking about it i i want to like i want
you want to preserve the new friendship
yeah there's something fascinating
though about like holding on to those
secrets and and having to
um
kind of throw people off the scent like
i know how he makes those videos that's
so wild too i know like prevent people
from figuring out the actual secrets and
then this company goes through all that
so this little like um
doppelganger that he has
it's not fair to call him a doppelganger
doppelganger's people that just like
look like somebody naturally he's just a
spanish he's a spanish thief
i'm in his country of origin now
standing he happens to believe he's from
spain
let's call him diego copperfield i
wonder what his name under the stage
name is i wonder is it copper field and
because those are english words that
mean other things i could you say is it
spanish is there a spanish well now that
you know spanish you should be able to
translate copper and field right um why
are you looking down on your phone well
sorry i was going to translate it i know
i'm just kidding i thought you should
just know that by now um field i don't
know that one
copper i don't know that those are those
are obscure copper is obscure these
field i should probably know anyway uh
diego copperfield
i i wonder like you know if i were david
copperfield i would go to a diego
copperfield show and just go in the
[ __ ]
heckle him heckle the [ __ ] out of him
that would be a justifiable heckling
oh yeah it's like oh where'd i see that
before oh right i created oh yeah
or just yell out what's gonna happen i
know how you did it
but he doesn't want people to know the
secrets if he couldn't do that true
it's a tricky position to be in
literally let's read a letter is that
your chair no no i'm not moving
okay this is from amy cher
so i'm gonna share it with you share
spelled like cher yeah no no like do you
mean the singer no like i'm just gonna
share this with you this spell cool
or charae
it could be charai
subject our intimate relationship
unbeknownst to you
dear justin and christian i've put off
writing this email since your first
episode with dax first i will just
clarify that i am female okay she knows
that wouldn't be that's funny and that's
funny and take that stress off you right
there now we can focus it's funny she
knows us i've always loved anything
justin has been in beginning with ed
thank you amy you are one of the actors
that i would see anything just because
you're in it it's really nice
like buying a weird al album and not
knowing any of the original songs
but that's not the point a few years ago
i was dating someone who i very much
considered my person and he died
oh boy
he was in his 40s and it was not
expected
through our relationship pretty much
anything we did had a soundtrack and so
listening to music ended up becoming
very difficult for me oh my god
i bet as a result i discovered podcasts
and shortly after i did you released
this one so putting together an actor i
adored with the concept i was really
embracing life really is short so yolo
[ __ ] sorry i'm in my 40s and still
clinging onto that was a no-brainer
wow yeah i bet both justin and christian
have made my runs cleaning cooking and
ignoring my children so much more
pleasant and i just wanted to say thanks
i love everything about the show and
you've both done a lot for me oh man
what a beautiful letter yeah my god
um truly thank you um the only thing
back to amy the only thing that is
nagged at me that was brought up on the
show a few times though a long time ago
so maybe i should let it go is the fact
that at least justin has not been to
montreal
not sure about christian yes i know
that's been nagging me too and it's been
coming up lately everyone i know has
been and loves it i've been it's there
you go i love it there you go but i i'd
like to go again because i haven't been
since i was in college
oh man college was a long time ago yeah
i'd really like to go again
but i remember having a great time there
i i and it's so close to me i mean it's
there's really no i have no excuse you
you would like it a lot i i bet um
because i love i've been spending time
in europe you can start learning french
on duolingo okay
okay
god i've almost given up on you have
yeah i haven't done it whatever who
cares before you give up completely you
should learn how to say copperfield yeah
that's spanish oh why don't i look it up
it could wait till after the show we're
still on the show i forgot okay back to
amy based on your love of austin in new
orleans i can't emphasize enough how
great my city is outside of winter
you have both done so much for me let me
bring this back to your attention and
just yolo your butts to montreal you
won't regret it i i'm going to
i am going to uh and yolo is um yeah i
never really said it out loud a lot but
it's a great expression
uh you only live once
i mean it's it's
it's great and true yeah well
both maybe not true but uh that's true
yeah maybe we'll be you'll be
reincarnated as a what's that kind of
turtle that you like that um is on
copper fields island oh aldabra tortoise
yeah maybe it'll be reincarnated as an
aldabra tortoise they're similar to i
think they're found i think the aldabra
islands i think they're near the say
shelley's or maybe it's the same you're
looking at me for help okay sorry i
can't help you but but my point is
they're related to the galapagos
tortoise because when those the
continental shift happened those two
little islands drifted apart cool and uh
that's why they're both that's another
place you'd like to go yes yeah that's
number one galapagos that's top on the
list i'd love to go to
the seychelles too seychelles is that
how you say it i don't know anyway
there's a lot of great wildlife there
unique to that island anyway um
thank you back to amy thanks again you
guys you are both wonderful amy oh thank
you amy what a nice letter uh uh would
you rather for my kids
best kind would you rather always need
to pee or always need to fart great
question
always need to always need to does that
mean you can't you can i don't quite
let's let's let's say that
let's say it's just the feeling of
having to do it you always have to do it
needing to pee can hurt a lot more
needing to
both will keep you up at night
um both are uncomfortable but i think he
is more uncomfortable oh i don't think
having to fart would keep me up oh it's
kept me up really yeah it would you
think fart yeah you got stuff going on
in your body what you've never been kept
away from at like a
like a
pinballing fart maybe kept me awake a
little bit but i'm i guess what i'm
saying is i could sleep with a fart in
my belly and i can't sleep if i have to
pee
that's a hell of a quote
um
that should go in roger's
you know what i'm saying though
yeah like if i really have to pee
there's no way i'm falling asleep that's
true i think you know why you know i bet
it is because we have
this built-in
fear
of wetting the bed yeah that's true so i
think because i ha at least i do i don't
speak for everybody but i think i have
that fear because i used to wet the bed
when i was a kid
um so i i'm so afraid of doing it
because it was such an awful feeling
when you did do it yeah shame shame that
um
i can't let myself relax enough to fall
asleep if i have to pee oh i suspect
that's part of it well wouldn't but i
have no fart shame but wouldn't it be
[ __ ] the bed i mean what if i've
never [ __ ] the bed so maybe that's so
proud if i had
that should be the name of my memoir
yeah i've never i've never [ __ ] the bed
the christian long story well assuming
that it continues to be true i'm sure
eventually i will [ __ ] the bed
but i've i've um i've never [ __ ] to bed
so i don't have that fear so having a
gas bubble in me doesn't give me that
inability to relax i bet that's part of
it maybe it would i see i just think it
hurts more to hold in pee it that too
that's why in general to answer this
question it's a good question yeah i
would rather have to fart than th that
feeling the need to farm the needs of
fart yeah both are so satisfying now
that i think about they're so satisfying
when you can relieve it they both would
be very frustrated i would rather
relieve the p than the fart
i think
you know when you have to go so badly
that there's like a a shutter of delight
when you're doing it it's the piss
shiver piss shiver
don't you ever get that like a full body
like so i'm saying yeah yeah whole body
yeah
it's like it's kind of like farting
you don't get that with most things
you get that with certain things but
it's very rare
yeah you just wonder what if other
people know about the pissed shiver what
if david copperfield's listening to this
i bet he's had piss shivers
yeah and i don't know if women get it it
might just be a man thing no it's just a
physiological thing oh really i think so
i think i've heard women do get it
really
yeah ladies shorties
they didn't
i'm curious about that if women get
pissed every time because i don't know
if every guy gets it either i know it's
something that i've always gotten oh but
especially when you have to go for a
long time when you finally go road trip
p oh man sometimes it's like an
uncontrollable bodily yeah
yeah it's like a car
oh man i just keep picturing david
copperfield listening to this i think
you'd be into it yeah because you're so
step down to earth
i'm imagining that the pre-interview
david copper right one that i had in my
head yeah i am you gotta shake that
loose like because now you know like the
p finally coming out of your urethra
well i think we finally jumped the shark
we have um
we've we [ __ ] the bed so to speak yeah i
don't think so this is a good episode
you think i think so um think i mean i
think amy really saved the episode
because that letter was incredible it
was and heart felt like she shared it
with us yeah i mean she's probably sick
of that kind of joke and i'm um i'm so
glad she wrote in i you know i know i'm
really glad she wrote in and
i hope more people continue to write in
and if they want to write in
it's life is short at wondry.com you
have a lot of uh desires hopes
i do
um
and let's let's also i like when people
write in i know it's great i love
reading those letters i wish we could
read more than one letter i know because
yeah but then the show would be too long
um so hopefully it was just the right
amount of time this show for all of you
and hopefully uh maybe even left you
wanting more
more talk about peace shivers
and [ __ ] at the bed
uh we're we're so happy you listened and
you joined us and we are so grateful to
the
master illusionist and now i dare say
my new friend you should all get his
book
it is called david copperfield's history
of magic yes and um do not go see
the fake david copperfield see the real
one yeah don't support some like
criminal some imposters faker what's the
word for imposter in spanish um
okay we're going to go because justin
has to go do spanish lessons and uh
we'll talk to you next week
life could be a dream
life
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted and produced by you
christian log also produced by megan v
monaco and katie v allen and senior
producer on this one is michelle miesha
lans audio engineer audio what engineer
sergio enriquez sure is executive
producer marshall louis yeah and for a
company that is wondering
[Music]
a funny funny idea for a short mission
possible um to set to the theme song of
mission impossible but uh
pending the rights
but uh someone's got to do something
that's quite easy
and it's all to the time
and they have to like they have the key
and they have to get into something and
it's very easy mission possible
short short film